5 g égale danger dans les manifs anti 5g
on entend des choses inquiétantes sur
cette technologie c'est vraiment
dangereux
salut thomas bonjour jody la 5g c'est
juste le nom de la cinquième génération
de téléphonie mobile elle doit permettre
de connecter plus d'objets beaucoup plus
rapidement et en dépensant moins
d'énergie mais c'est pas dangereux pour
la santé à cause des ondes
électromagnétiques et des antennes
relais alors non les agences sanitaires
ont synthétisé des milliers d'études il
estime que sa présente justement pas de
risque particulier en plus les antennes
5g sont conçus pour s'éteindre
automatiquement lorsqu'elle n'émettent
pas il ya quand même plein de gens qui
développent des vraies pathologies quand
ils sont à proximité d'une antenne
relais par exemple ce qui semble c'est
qu'on a des gens qui sont électro folk
qui ont une hantise de tout ce qui
serait susceptible de les exposer à des
ondes électromagnétiques
ces personnes qui souffrent probablement
réellement sont en fait victime de ce
qu'on appelle l'effet nocebo l'effet
nocebo oui c'est le contraire de l'effet
placebo l'effet placebo c'est le
phénomène psychosomatiques qui fait
qu'on va mieux parce qu'on croit à
l'efficacité d'un traitement est bien
l'effet nocebo agi dans le sens inverse
on développe effectivement des symptômes
parce qu'on est persuadé que quelque
chose nous rend malades il ya d'autres
rumeurs qui nous disent que le coc u19
un lien avec la 5g ça c'est un mythe qui
a été propagée en particulier par une
association anthroposophique un
mouvement qui est considéré comme
sectaires leurs propos c'est que les
grandes épidémies ne sont pas dus à des
virus mais au développement de grandes
technologies la radio la télévision ou
internet mais comme par hasard le coc
u19 a commencé pile au moment où l'on
commencé à déployer la 5g et l'épicentre
de l'épidémie là one est aussi la
première ville à être entièrement
couverte par la 5g qu'est-ce que tu
réponds à ça c'est pas parce qu'on a
deux phénomènes qui surviennent en même
temps qu'il existe forcément un lien
entre les deux mais c'est troublant
quand même non parce qu'en fait houran
passé qu'une ville parmi beaucoup
d'autres avoir été équipée en 5 j or
l'épidémie n'est pas apparu dans ses
autres villes à ce moment là il ya des
lieux très équipés en 5 g ou pourtant on
n'a pas du tout vu l'épidémie se
développer par exemple la corée du sud
et l inverse il ya des lieux pas du tout
équipés en 5 g comme les territoires
français d'outre-mer on a pourtant vu
les flambées du virus ok mais ce qu'on a
assez de recul pour juger de l'innocuité
de la 5g des ondes électromagnétiques en
général d'après les spécialistes il n'y
a aucune raison de penser que cette
technologie puisse provoquer des
problèmes de santé après on peut pas
empêcher que certains charlatans ou
certains complotistes jouent sur la peur
de l'inconnu pour faire passer un
discours alarmiste accusé les
scientifiques et les autorités
sanitaires d'être malveillants ou pire
incompétent mais souvent eux-mêmes bas
ils sont ni compétents ni bienveillant
et s'ils ont raison de deux choses l'une
ou bien on a des milliers de
scientifiques très compétent qui
participent sciemment un vaste complot
contre la santé depuis des décennies ou
bien marins ajustent des marchands de
peur des bourgs ou thérapeutique des
lanceurs de fausses alertes qui sur
internet raconte n'importe quoi pour
vendre des formations et monétiser leur
chaîne youtube toi tu demande s'ils ont
raison moi je me demande toujours à qui
ces théories du complot pop bien profité
[Musique]